o kızın hayatında Bence bazı önemli
sorular var bizim hayatlarımızı
iyileştiren geliştiren bizim fark
etmemizi sağlayan Bizim daha ileriye
gitmemiz iyi ve kendimizi daha ileride
görüntü sağlayan sorular var bu
sorulardan biri ve Bence en
önemlilerinden biri bir hayatımda şu
için şenlendiren nedir
Evet şimdi bütün otobüs burada
izleyenler olarak bu anlamı soruyu
kendinize sorabilirsiniz Bu soruyu
sorduğunuzda
Az önce What yükselecek bir kelime
olabilir birisi olabilir bu bir süreç
olabilir bugün anlatılabilir suyu
kendinizi sorduğumuzda cevap geliyor şu
an gelebilir Yarın gelebilir bir yıl
sonra gelebilir ama mutlaka gelir Eğer
bir cevap geldiyse ya da geleceksen tam
o anda Aslında tutkunuz lavabo bağlantı
kurunuz tutkumuz a dokunduğunuz veya da
tutkunuzu bir kapı açtığımız diye
tutkular insan hayatında çok mu kıymetli
şeyler ve sade insan hayatında belasını
Evren için çok kıymetli bir şey bütün
girişimlerimiz bütün bilimsel çalışmalar
bütün sanat çalışmaları bütünsel
resimlerimiz bütün yaşam gelişimleri
hepsi canlılığın ve insan atıklarından
kaynaklanıyor Einstein'ın Bu çok güzel
bir söz var diyor gençler Aslında çöz
Bu sadece tutkulu biçimde ne Rabbim bir
işi tutkuyla yaptığımızda bu çok küçük
bir işten büyük bir şey araba değişik
değişik lira bu işin niteliği her zaman
çok fazla değişiyor ve değişen litrelik
bi zp çok önemli bir nicelik olarak
karşımıza çıkıyor
bu ve insan okusunu bulduğunda Eda
tutkusunu yaşamaya başladığında o
insanın yeni kapıları açılır Tutkusu
yaşayan insan onu derinine inmek ister
ucundan daha çok şey öğrenmek ister
keşfetmek ister ve Utku hiç çekirdek
yaşam enerjisi doğru arasında bir coşku
doğurur amaç doğru bir anlam doğru ki
dönüş Alırım Dün t-rex İstanbul'un son
şundan programından bir konuşma
yayınlanmıştı Mehmet Eroğlu'nun
saldırıyla rekabet etmek diye tavsiye
ederim herkese çok güzel bir konuşma
orada Mehmet Eroğlu amca tutkuyla çok
güzel bir şey söyleyeceğim Tutku insanın
tutkalı dırbalı çok beğendim Yani Tutku
insanın tutmalıdır ve tutkuyla devam
eden hayatın tutkuyla yaşayan insanlar
bu
bu ballı bağlanmış gibi sıkıcı hayatına
devam ederler fakat tutkusunu yitiren
insanlar bağlanmamış casına harflerin
devamında dağılırlar kaybolurlar yeterli
O yüzden tutkunuzu bulmak tutkumuzu
aramak ve tutkuyu bulduysak bunun
peşinden gitmek inanılmaz önemli
hayatlarımızı bu tutkunuzu bozuk ya da
arıyoruz ya da diğerlerinden tut tut
kanalımız ve bunun gerçekleştirmek
istiyoruz artık bir gerçeğe dönüştürmek
istiyoruz bundan Somut bir şey almak
istiyorum ya da Bir hayalden sonra bir
şey almak istiyoruz Burada bence iki
tane parametre çıkıyor insan hayatında
bunlardan birincisine motivasyon sınıf
Zamanı kullanmak ve zaman şimdi
bu motivasyonla başlayalım Bence canlı
olmak motif Olmaktır canlı baktığımız ın
canlılık her zaman yaşamsal
faaliyetlerin devam ettirmek için ayakta
kalmak için üremek için beslenmek için
Avlanmak için hep çok motive Yani bizim
başka parametreler imiz değişken lerimiz
devreye giriyor Bunlardan birisi var de
zihinsel yapımı zor korkularımız ölümün
bilincimiz olabilir Bir şeyler
içimizdeki o canlılığın verdiği çekirdek
motivasyonu kırıyor bence onu Göl
geliyor Aslında içimizde her zaman orada
olan sadece canlı olmamızdan kaynaklanan
bir motivasyon var pek ihtiyacımız olan
şey onu bir gölge etmemek ona bir sen
bir devam et yani Benimki de götüreceğim
yere götür ben seni izliyorum demek
zihinlerimiz özellikle düşüncelerimiz
bir ol
O çok fazla düşünürüz bir şey yapmadan
önce çok fazla düşünürüz bir eyleme
geçmeden önce çok fazla düşünürüz ve o
çekirdek motivasyonumuz canlılığın ve
ayrı bu şekilde motivasyonunuzu genelde
kaybolur ya bu canlının motivasyon dan
bahsettiğim şey ne yapıyor servis
Sarmaşık ne duvarda ilerlemek Yani bir
olmak için her zaman çok mutlu aslanı
almak için çok mutluyum o canlı
hatırlamamız lazım sadece çocuklara
bakabilirsiniz çocukları baktığımızda o
motivasyonu görüyoruz Şimdi burada biraz
duralım burada ben kendi hayatından
bilgi alacağım tutkulardan konuştukları
gerçekleşmiş var motivasyon ve Zamanı
kullanmak şimdi 2015'in sonlarında yaz
aylarında lan Mor ve çektim Norveç'te
çok güzel saat Macera dolu bir sırt
çantalı yolculuk yaptım var baştan
İzlanda Deniz dalgalarda arka nefis bir
yolculuk yaptım ve çok
o insanla tanıştım yolculuklar da sırt
çantalı bir yolculuk otostopla yapıyorum
inanılmaz keyfin sana atmışım inanılmaz
güzel insanlarla konuşuyoruz Böyle
İzlanda böyle çok uzun süren çok fazla
uzun değil Ama belli bir süre alan bir
buçuk aya yakın bir yolculuktu sonra ben
bu yolculukta insanlardan inanılmaz
şeyler olarak insan keşfetme çok açık
bir canlı olarak çalışmaya başladı bana
insandan çok şey öğreniyorum
bir insanın derinliklerini anlamaya
başlıyorum ve insanı hayatımda Aslında
yeni bu kadar keşfettim yeni bu kadar
sevdiğimi anlamaya başladım ve
izlanda'da bir kasabada yürüyorum ona
bir şey fark ettim orada insandım bir
kasabada yürürken içmiş aramıştım
insanla ilgili ve orada fark ettim ki
bir tutkuya dönüşmüş aslında insan benim
için ve bu tutku Bu enerji oradaki A bu
Coşku bu İlhan O proje dönüştü orada bir
projeye başladığında net yeni çanta
alacak ufak bir tutkuydu kendim için
yapmak istediğin temelinde ülkelere
gidip insanlarla seyahat edip
bu insanların hikayelerini dinledim
fotoğraflarını çektim bunları
birleştirdim birşeyde Fakat bu küçük
Tutku çok büyük yerlere duymuştum
Allahım buna başladıktan sonra
ülkelerden insanlar binlerce insan
hikayeleri onlarla sohbet etmek için
uluslararası ulusal gazetelerde çok
şeyler yaşadım Bu proje başladıktan
sonra birkaç yıl devam ettim son
yılından şu ana kadar da bir ara verdim
şimdi yeniden profesyonel bir şey
oluşturuyoruz bunu Temel ve Dijital
biraz koymuştur yeniden başlayacağız ve
için binden fazla insanla tanıştım
Sadece proje içinde ve tam olarak o
İslam ve için Şenlendirici Ayy üzerine
gitmemiş hissettiğim
Bu bir gerçek oluşturdum Aslında şimdi
buna o zaman tarafına dönmek istiyorum
Bu projeye başladığımda tıp fakültesinde
adam tıp fakültesinde okuyorum sınavlar
var çok şeyle uğraşıyorum kolay değil
bir anda kendimi dijital projenin içinde
kullanıyorum ben o zamana kadar ne
dijital proje bilirim ve fotoğraf
çekmeyi profesyonel bilirim ne kadar
düzenleyebilirim Ne o kadar sosyoloji
bilirim yani bir sosyolojik projesinin
içine girdim Aslında kendim nedir Nisa
dünyada bir proje olabilir o yüzden bir
şeyler öğrenmek zorunda kaldım ve aynı
zamanda işte ben edebiyat uğraşıyorum
müzikle uğraşıyorum bir şeyler daha
yapmak istiyorum Abla bir anda öyle çok
kısıtlı bir zaman içine çok fazla şey
sıkıştırma gereken farketmez Ve zamanın
değeri ve kıymeti ile en uzun
Bu baş Tum yerlerden biri de bulaşık
oldu bakıyorum hayatıma Yani ben de
çalışayım sınavların biçim bulma yapayım
Tamam dedim o zaman zamanı kullanmayı
uğramam lazım zamanı nasıl verimli
kullanacağım zamanınız kontrol edeceğim
bunu var ama lazım ve odan andan
itibaren zamanla ilgili zamanı anlamak
ve onu yönetmekle ilgili birçok şey
kattım Kendine de çok farkındalığın
gelmiş Bence şimdi iki parametre var
burada bu anlattığım proje Tıp Fakültesi
vesaire bir zamanı kontrol etmek verimli
kullanmak iki en yeni bir şey öğrenmek
istiyorum Yeni bir şey öğrenecek
öğrendiğim zaman ne kadar zamanı yazmaya
çalışıyorum bir zamanı kontrol etmeli
şimdi
Ya ben zamanı kontrol etme zamanı
yönetmenin en önemli noktası odaklandık
odaklanmak insanın oldukça yitirdiği
Fakat çok fazla ihtiyacı olan bir şey
bugün dünyada insanların odağın
neredeyse tamamen 70 şurada bir şeyler
çok zor odaklanıyoruz çok uygulamamızı
kaybediyoruz ve odaklanmanın yaptığımız
herhangi bir işi bu Akın'ın olabilir o
Sen olabilir mesleki olabiliriz anlat
olabilir herhangi bir şey ne kadar iyi
götüreceğin aslında hiç farkında değiliz
ve dünyamızda bir uyaran Cennet zaten
sosyal medya var işte haberlerimiz acıya
da çok kolay boşluğa bir durumda çok
kolay dikkatimizi dağıtıyoruz ve hayır
demeyi öğrenmemiz gerekiyor odaklanmak
için şimdi buradan kendi
ben bundan bir ay önce falan odaklanmaya
değildi mütevazı bir araştırma yaptım
bazı anket soruları hazırladım ve
insanların Gerçekten bu konuda neler
düşündüğünü neler yaşadıklarını anlamak
istiyorum sorulardan biri şuydu her
soruya ortalama 2 bin kişi katılımı
cevap çıkan cevaplar mm için cevapları
ilk soru şuydu ne kadar herhangi bir işe
ve çalışmaya başladığınızda ne kadar o
da kalabiliyorsunuz dakikadan ağzını 30
dakikadan fazla rakı odaklanma süresini
almasıdır insanların yüzde 51'i 30
dakikadan az yağlı şimdi 30 dakika
Aslında çok kısa bir süre inanılmaz Kısa
bir süre 30 dakika vm-2000 için yüzde
51'i 30 dakikadan az o da kalabiliyorum
dedi Başka dedim ki ağır ne işe
başladığınız bir ders çalışıyorsun
herhangi bir şey yapıyorsunuz
o telefona bakma ihtiyacı ya da sosyal
medya girme ihtiyacı acaba uğraştınız
başka bir şey bakma ihtiyacın duyuyormuş
çalışmaya başladığımızda insanların
yüzde altmış 2'deki Evet duyuyorum Lan
telefona bakmadan sosyal medyaya
bakmadan bulamıyorum o da ama
sürdüremiyorum dedi bir şey daha sordum
Dedim ki işiniz var şuan Elinizde bir iş
var bakalım yapmak istemiyorsunuz Şu an
ne yaparsanız yoksa arkadaşlar mısınız
insanların yüzde sekseni ki siz belki
başvurmuş yapmam mutlaka arkadaşlarım
şimdi odaklanıyoruz alacağız
odaklanmamız çok kötü ve odaklanma
üzerine çalışmamızın bize ne kadar
faydalı olacağını da kestir diyoruz
zaman ve böylece giderek azalarak
sürüyor Yani ve şöyle bilgiler var var
mesela bir o yüzden çalışıyorsunuz bir
Ne yapıyorsunuz ders çalışıyorsun ediniz
ki beni saniyeliğine sosyal medya bak
Instagram'a için YouTube acı coronavirüs
vaka sayısının bakayım Bu arada bu içine
bakmayı unuttum ne olabilir yani bir
saniye bakayım ne kaybederim yani geri
döneceğim beyninâ nörofizyoloji sizde bu
olay aslında bir infiale yol açıyor Siz
odaklandığımız çalışıyorsunuz
İslamiyet'in ettiniz Aşkımız sosyal beni
sonra kapatırız beyin aynı odaklanmaya
geri kazanmak için tam 23 dakika arıyor
Eğer 2-3 dakika boyunca Siz o da ağzı
tamamen kaybetmiş oluyorsunuz ve o o da
kesmeden önce ki o da gücüne ancak 23
dakika sonra ulaşabiliyorsunuz bu
inanılmaz bir kayıp Aslında ve bugün A.Ş
bu sayısıyla çok çabuk tüketmek
istiyoruz Etrafınıza bir bakın da çok
koyamayız artık ince uzun videolar
izlemek istemiyorum kitap okumak
istemiyor at dinlemek istiyoruz izlemek
istemiyoruz kısa videolar ve her şeyi
öğrenmek istiyorum uzun dersin demek
istemiyoruz kalk bilgi istiyoruz insan
odaklanmasını kaybettikçe tüketmeye
odaklanıyor Ve gittikçe de odan daha çok
kaybediyor O yüzden tutku ve hayal
gerçekleştirmede abi zamanı kullanmadığı
zamanımızı verimli kullanmaları en önem
vereceğimiz ve en dikkat etmemiz gereken
şeylerden biri odaklanmak nedeni
demiştim odaklanmak için bize ne lazım
hayır demek lazım şimdi burada ağabey
testten bahsedeyim ben size özdenetim
insanın özlediğini İnsan iradesi 1970
yılında Stanford Üniversitesinde
Boğazlarım Işıl'ın ve yeteneği var bunu
yasla çok günü
bu Mahmut o testi diye bir de Neymiş bu
çocuklarla yapılan bir şöyle oluyor
araştırmacılar çocukları odaları aldılar
odalarda çocukların önüne bir tane
marshmallow koyuyorlar şeker şeker
koyuyorlar diyorlar ki çocuklar bu
şekeri şu an yiyebilirsiniz alırsınız
fakat şöyle yapabiliriz lan oradan
çıkacağım Ona göre geleceğim Eğer bu
süreç boyunca Sen bu şekilde yapmazsan
ben sana bir şekilde da vereceğim iki
şeker gibi edeceksin kendini
denetleyebilir Sen zeki kaçta geleceksin
ya da şu anda zevk alabilirsin
çocukların bir kısmı şekerleri yiyor bir
kısmında yemiyor bunların ülkeler
arasında farklı sonuçları var
kamerundaki derin yüzde yetmiş yemiyor
Can Almanya'daki tr130 yiyor onu bir
kenar
16 şuradan içinden
daha sonra bu çalışmanın polovak
çalışmaları yapılır kova devam çok şükür
devam çalışmalarını çocuklar izliyor
Hayat Tamam Bu çocukların Boğazlarım
açmıyoruz çekebilir Boğazlar yemeden Ne
oldu Bu çocukların hayatında önemli
birlikte Neyi ulaştılar abi izledikten
sonra çocukları şöyle bir şey var
maaşını dolu şekeri yemeyen çocuklar
haklarından 100 de 50 daha başarılı
oluyorlar akademik alanda ve profesyonel
sadece başarılı olmuyorlar 100 de 50
daha az bağımlı oluyor herhangi bir şey
herhangi bir şey bağımlılıktan basıyorum
Dolayısıyla çocukluktan başlayarak bu
özdenetimi ve insan iradesini ne kadar
önemli olduğunu anlıyoruz Aslında
hayatımızın devam etsin ne kadar
kıymetli olduğunu anlıyoruz özdenetim
yoksa geliştirilip yoksa yaratılabilir
varsa geliştirilebilir Yani o kadar
bunlar odaklanmada özdenetimle
mı yoksa İnan şeylerde bütün kişisel
özellikler geliştirilebilir şeyler
kuvvetlendirebilirim yani siz değerli
özlediğimizde Ya ben bir adet olamıyorum
ben hayır diyemiyorum ben kendimden
ekleyemiyorum diyorsanız bu üzerine
gayet çalışabilirsiniz
geliştirebilirsiniz şimdi ne demiştim
ama proje kısmına başladığımda hayatın
bir zaman sıkışmasına girdi ve burada
kısmı odaklanmıştı bir zamana kontrol
etmek verimli kullanmak için yeni bir
şey olmak istiyorum Ben yeni bir şey
öğrenmek ister öğrenmek istediğimde Ne
kadar zamana ihtiyacım var burada böyle
bir mahkumla verin Ayşe duymuşsunuzdur
abla çok severim çizginin dışında ki
şimdi balkoncular var mı
Bu bir konuda bir yetenek da bir işte ve
ustalaşmak için birşeyde ustalaşma mız
için 10 bin saf ihtiyacımız var 10000
saat ediyoruz örneğini veriyor bilgisini
veriyor başka ünlü isimlerin örnekleri
var hayatlarındaki 10000 saate
ulaşmalarında ki şansı anlatıyor olarak
nasıl hayatlarının insanların da 10000
saatleri ulaşmasını olaylar açtığını
anlatıyor ve a mesela videosunu örneği
işte sahibi İngiltere'de bir bardağı
çalmaya başlıyorlar ve her gün canlı
performansı doğar ve inanılmaz saatler
boyunca söylüyorlar ve bu onların bu
kötü kesme aletlerini çok geliştiriyorum
için Neyse on bir saattir benim 10'in
saati bir böyle daha dikkatli baktım
38 saat Işık 1250 günü yapıyor Kısa bir
süre miyim Aslında göz korkutucu
olabilir Şimdi o zaman bizim işi uğramak
istiyorum lan İlk onu da yeteneğim
olduğunu hissediyorum evet sıfırdan bir
şey yapmak istiyorum 11 saat sistemi
ihtiyacım var yani gerçekten bu savaşmak
için onu bir saatten başka bunu
yapabileceğim şans yokmuş çıkan burada
boş kalkman nedir İnsanın güzel bir
heves konuşması var burada bahsettiğim
şey var bu ilkini sadece hoş kalkmak
izleyebilirsiniz gayet güzeldir burada
bir şey anlatıyor şimdi değil iki kalem
buraya burada Sızım klasik göstereyim
şimdi şu bizim grafiğimiz olsun Tamam
kalmadı anlatışı rahatsız etmeyeceğim
O çok sıkkın bu grafiğin bu ekseni
yeteneklerimizle işlerimizde geliştirmek
istediğiniz şeyler de ilerleme mesafemiz
olsun yukarı çıktıkça Usta ulaşıyoruz
Tamam yukarı çıktıkça bu çalışıyoruz
alttaki grafiğimiz ise zaman olsun Şimdi
bu artık nasıl ilerleyecek herhangi bir
yetenek geliştirmek istiyorum
hayatımızda bir şeylere bakın yaptığımız
geliştiriniz yetenekler öyle
öğrendiğiniz bir program Yeni
öğrendiğiniz bir da herhangi bir şey
olursa ne yaparız kısa zamanlar
geçiririz ve çok şey öğreniriz
enstrümanının kabataslak notalarını
nereye tutacağımız nasıl basacağı mızı
bir şeyler eee hızlı uğrarız yeni bir
yazılım öğrenirken bunu yine hızlı
yaparız kabataslak şeyleri hızlı
öğrenmiş o zaman önce ne olur bir zaman
eksilen de zaman Eksildim ağzı bir süre
bu Fakat bu çok özgelişim göstermek
istedim önce böyle başlar bir şeyler de
yetenek geliştirmek Bir şeylerimiz
ilerletmek fakat sonra boş Aslında böyle
devam etmez sonra gittikçe fazla zaman
aramaya başlarız artık belli bir
seviyede bir şey biliyoruz dur hiç fazla
zaman alacağız Fakat bu sefer
ayrıldığımız zamanı oranla kazandığımız
yetenek gelişimi oransal olarak daha
düşük olur o zaman grafik nasıl
ilerleyecek ben şöyle ilerleyecek değil
mi sanki Plato çizilecek yüzleşecek gibi
verecek bak ne olacak asla birleşmeyecek
zaman devam ettikçe i şeyler sonsuza dek
gelişmeye devam edecek Bakalım artık
eskisi gibi o ilmi kurumayacak 20'si
azalacak şimdi koş kalma tamam diyor 11
insan ustalaşma orada Tamam peki ya bir
yer yok mu bir yer yok benim geçemediğim
için hakim olduğunu hissedecek kadar
yaptım aynı zamanda kendimi
düzeltebilecek kadar bildiği Eğer yok mu
buraya ulaşmak ne kadar sürer Bu mu
ilgili araştırmalar yapıyor çalışmalar
yapıyor ve diyor ki bu grafik böyle
ilerliyor ya ulaşırken Şurada şöyle
çevirsem olmak istemiyorum hayali
görmeye çalışalım şurada tam yatağı
ulaşmaya ilk başladığı yer değirmenin
iyice düştüğü yerde NATO çizmeye çok
yaklaştığı yerde bir yer var bir nokta
var O noktaya ne kadar sürede
ulaşabileceğim e baktığımda diyor ne
kadar sürede O noktaya gidebileceğimiz
anlamaya çalışıyor ve bu noktada 20 saat
yani bir yetenek geliştirmek istiyorum
Yeni bir enstrüman öğrenmek istiyorum
yeni bir dil öğrenmek istiyorum Yeni bir
yazılım öğrenmek istiyorum 20 saatim var
Bir saat sonra bu öğrendiğim şey kendimi
düzeltebilecek kadar basit şeyleri
gerçekleştirebilecek kadar öğrenebilir
onun kendi Örneğin Kuleli öğrenmek
mesela sıfırdan kule çalmaya başlamış
Vertex konuşmasını içinde güzel böyle
bir Dünyası yapmış 20 saatini doldurmuş
bu orada çok güzel bir şeyler basit
şarkılar çaldı çok oldu gayet Bu neden
önemli 11 saatiniz varsa lütfen 10000
saati kullanan 10000 saat boyunca
ustabaşının yapmak istediğinizde Onun
yerini hiçbir şey tutamaz hiçbir
söylediğimiz Onun yerini tutamaz Bak bu
neden önemli bir Tutkun da ilerlemek
istiyorum bir hayalimi gerçekleştirmek
istiyorum Bana motivasyon lazım
motivasyon gözünü baştan çok korkutur
Sam birşeye başlamam da ilerlemem de
kadar zorlaşır O yüzden önce motive
olabilmen lazım 20
Ya neyse benim için bu yüzden önemli bu
yirmi saat birisini ıslak Kullanıma ve
konuşmayı izleyebilirsiniz gayet
cevizine konuşma eğlenceli bir konuşma
olmaya saatte gözünüzü korkutmasın şimdi
üzerine konuştuk zaman üzerine
konuştukları gerçeklere dönüştürmek için
zamana ve zamanı kullanma ihtiyacımız
var ve cesaret göstermeye ihtiyacımız
var ve kendimiz olmaya ihtiyacımız var
Cesaret de motivasyon gibi her zaman
insanın içinde olan bir şey güçte
içimizde cesaretle İçinizde yine
yaptığınız şeylerin bilinç düşünceler
korkularla bu gölge etmek oluyor ve
tutkularda yemiş öyle bir şeyler
söylemek istiyorum bitireceğim yavaş
yavaş
ben size ait olan şeyler çıkıyor o zaman
Tutkusu tam olarak birbirine benzemez
ikimizin Tutkusu evrene karşılamaz
benimtutkum bana hissettirdiği şey sen
de aynı şekilde ilerlemez ve hepimizin
canlı olarak burada bir yolculuğu var bu
yolculukta öğreneceğimiz şeyler var
deneyeceğim şeyler var tutkuları Bence o
öğrenmeniz gereken şeylerde
geliştirmemiz gereken şeylerde bu
deneyimlere Işık tutuyorlar hepimizin
hayattan beklediği bazı cevaplar var
amaçlar anlamlar bir şey tutkular Bizim
kendimize ait olan cevapları
ilerlememizi sağlıyorlar O yüzden size
ait olan tutkular un bu yüzden çok
önemli yani tutkuların bu yüzden
kesinlikle peşinden gitmek zorundasınız
bu Çünkü siz yapmazsanız başka kimse
sizin tutumlarımız için peşinizden
beşinden etmeyecek şimdi
ve garantiler yok hayatımızda Garanti
aramanız gerekiyor Bu da Bağış'ın bir
sözüne yer vereyim gölge Bağış
bu garanti istiyorsanız biz hayatı
istemiyorsunuz demektir kulaksızı aitler
cesaret motivasyonu zaman kulluğunu
hepsi yapabileceğimiz şeyler hepsi
altından kalkabileceği niz şeyler
bu çocuklarınız sizin ben onları gidelim
ve alıyorum çünkü sizin yerinize kimse
onları bağlayacak ve siz almazsınız Aaa
onlar öylece o enerjiler yitip gitmiş
olacaklar için izine şenlendiriyor sa
lütfen uşağı kandırmayı bütün ve ışık